il y a eu 1500 projets je crois donc à
la fois zone et c'est d'ailleurs une
bonne nouvelle en soi c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de créativité beaucoup d'envié
les projets ils sont très divers peuvent
tout suivi six projets en particulier il
ya des bonnes idées à la fois pour le
court terme pour le long terme et un
certain nombre de projets qui tournait
autour de comment est-ce qu'on peut
mieux comprendre les phénomènes se passe
à partir de la donne et comment le virus
se répand comment est ce qu'on arrive à
avoir des actions les plus efficaces
pour lutter contre la propagation de
virus il y à un certain nombre de
projets qui tournait autour d'eux
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir ré
ouvrir les lieux de notre activité
quotidienne que ce soit les commerces
dans leur ensemble les lieux de
divertissement y puis par ailleurs
d'autres projets par exemple sur bas
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir petit à
petit réouvrir les frontières entre nos
pays il ya eu pas mal d'initiatives qui
seront prometteuses sur des passeports
des certifications des mesures barrières
au niveau des frontières enfin voilà
beaucoup de créativité encore une fois